Now you're ready to write
your own delegates.
The challenge up for
this lesson has three text
fields with customized behavior.
A zip code text field that only allows
digits with a maximum of five digits.
A dollar sign text field that
begins with the text for $0.00, and
then fills in the dollar
figures as digits are added.
And finally a text field that can only
be edited when this switch is set to on.
Here in the first field once I get
to five digits I can't type anymore.
Here in the second field the digits
fill in from right to left.
And there are always two
digits beyond the decimal.
By the way, don't forget that
Cmd+K toggles the keyboard.
In the third field, the user has to
flip this switch in order to add text.
You can see that tapping inside the
first two fields brings up the number
pad instead of the QWERTY keyboard.
You can set this in the attribute
inspector in Storyboard.
Actually, let's open up
the utilities pane and
take a minute to explore
the attribute inspector.
This is a super convenient way to
configure UI kit view components.
Here you can set your placeholder text.
So you might want to to put something
like, Type your zip code here.
Here you can configure the clear button
like the one you saw on the Safari
search bar.
Here you can set capitalization.
If you add something
like a confirmation code,
you might want all characters
to be capitalized.
And here's the keyboard type, which for
the zip code we want set to number pad.
And just two more tips before
you move on to the challenge.
You're going to need to set
the delegates for your text fields.
If you want to do this in Storyboard
remember your delegate is just
a property.
So you're going to look for it in
Storyboard where you always look for
properties, in the pop-up
connections menu.
And here under outlets you
can see your delegate.
Also, for manipulating text
you might want to revisit
these two lines of code from
the emoji textField delegate.
The end of the string
class has a method named
stringByReplacingCharactersInRange.
It's perfect to use in
a UI text field delegate.
This method is helpful when you need
to build new strings from typed input.
In order to use this method, Swift
strings are usually cast to NSStrings.
In this case the variable newText
represents the text that will
be displayed.